ce canadien partage son temps entre le
québec et l'ukraine depuis dix ans il
séjourné dans la maison de sa femme dans
le sud quand la russie a lancé son
offensive depuis le 1er mars il vit sous
occupation des forces russes au
calendrier 55 jours
sur les plus et en clair
il occupe ses journées à préparer des
repas pour des familles ont besoin parce
qu'ils ont de la chance ils ont encore
beaucoup de provisions c'est sa femme
une ukrainienne qui les livre car lui
sort peu comme étrangers il est
convaincu qu'il sera arrêté il est
confiné dans son jardin et son quartier
ils évitent tout contact avec les
soldats russes qu'il a appris à
reconnaître même quand ils ne sont pas à
bord de véhicules de l'armée mais aux
rouilles et
vincent s'il était encore possible pour
certains ukrainien de fuir la région
moyennant un paiement secret il dit que
l'étau se resserre
on a bloqué les accès le pouvoir sortir
de la ville même si les gens voulaient
payer
donc des conseils de vraiment garder
toutes les populations
on annonce de l'êta blement cette fois
ci la mobilisation des gens et même des
adolescents a ses raisons et but et on y
met
comme chair à canon c'est paradoxal
encore plus troublant c'est la
déportation des civils par autocar vers
la russie ce n'est plus une rumeur dit
il mais là trois réalités
dans la région
présentement des centres de tri les
campements où on se parle les enfants
des parents et grands parents
et des hommes
et une fois que ce semble de traitement
la posséder on les achemine du côté
russe dans la région de rostock temps il
par la suite ils sont réexpédiés dans
des régions de si c'est ça c'est ce
qu'on peut faire les amener population
en 2022
on se doit déjà retourné ya
75 ans pensait
simplement
l'histoire se répète
mais cette fois c'est sous ses propres
yeux les apprécier les autres car ils
sont trop importants c'est des gens qui
ne
ils communiquent constamment avec des
amis médecins qui confirme que les gens
meurent tous les jours souvent de crise
cardiaque ou faute de médicaments
et
[Musique]
la dernière fois qu'il est allé en ville
c'était au début de la guerre et la
route était jonché de cada depuis son
secteur est constamment survolée par des
chasseurs des hélicoptères et du renfort
est arrivé ce week-end
qu'est ce qui vous arrive et
craignant
sauf qu'elles ont été repoussés dit-il
de plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres par
l'armée russe qui a miné les champs et
les routes secondaires
en attendant une porte de sortie ils
organisent l'installation de réfugiés
ukrainien au canada jamais
les gens québec donc avoir des enfants
qui vont grandir
mais son sort à nous comme celui de
centaines de milliers d'ukrainiens
demeure incertain